you say kikuchi who's having quite a
year his 16th start 6-3 record in the
era just over three third time as a
charm this is his third year in the
major leagues and he just made his first
major league all-star team so
congratulations to him and the yankees
have runners on it first and second with
one away you say looking for a ground
ball the stretch and they all want to
stanton swing and a high pop up into
shallow right field and down the line
long run henry going out dylan moore it
is going to be moore who makes the catch
right on the right field line the throw
to third cut off by crawford and the
runners have to stay dillon moore way
back to his left a long run for dylan a
long run for mitch haniger two on two
outs no score and the battle will be
first baseman luke voight
and voight rips that to left field to
base it aaron judge being waved around
third here he comes the throw is high
judge scores it's an rbi single for luke
voight and the yankees take a
one-nothing lead and now they have
runners at second and third two outs and
the battery shortstop glaber torres who
had the night off last night swung on
and drilled to left field it is a base
head gloved beautifully by long one run
scores and two runs score voigt scores
it's a two run base hit for gleber
torres and the yankees for the second
night in a row take a three-nothing
first-inning lead
you say he's ready so is gardner now
here's the stretch and again the one-two
pitch fastball strike three called got
him looking nick nelson you look at his
numbers to be his ninth game his second
start and the era elevated at 9.75
and it's the second start of the year
the first one did not go great
swing and miss nice change up there from
nelson one down
two on and two outs and that'll bring up
designated hitter jake fraley here's the
stretch and the three-nothing pitch way
inside and it gets away from sanchez
here comes hannigaran to score and the
mariners get a run on a wild pitch ball
four to jake crayley the mariners have
the bases loaded and luis sessa
is coming in three walks and a hit
batter served up by nick nelson
and the pitch is hit on the ground to
short
and taurus will step on the back to end
the inning
one run no hits
as la castro grounds to base it into
shallow left center but castro takes a
big turn he's going for two and he is in
with a double
one on and one away and now the castro
is on at third base
judge with three home runs in his last
seven ball games two for five last night
a run banded in
judge
hammers that high
deep and hold on
crushed
a two-run launch job
from aaron judge
and the yankees lead is 5-1
runners their leads and again the
one-two pitch swung out on a fly ball
into deep center tremell going back to
the one he tracked near the wall he is
there and makes the catch braces himself
up against the center field wall as he
makes the grab and that will retire the
side the yankees add two more
swinging a ground ball right side off to
his left dylan moore gobbles it up
throws the first in time to get her
shella so quickly two outs and now that
is six in a row retired by you say
kikuchi
swing and a miss strike three that is
strikeout number five for you say
kikuchi and after the rough start this
young man has settled down that is seven
in a row retired by you say halfway
point right-hander domingo herman
vermont four and five with a four and a
half era 15 starts on the year he comes
on in relief there's the 2-2
half swing did he go
i guess he did
there's some way to do a game this is
something
this is beautiful in seattle tonight
swing and a miss beautiful change up
back-to-back strikeouts for vermont and
with you now up to the top of the order
and here's jp crawford another left-hand
hitter and the pitch is hit in the air
to center field
coming in as gardening to make the catch
and harmon comes on and has a one two
three
the pitch
swinging a big bounder the third or
shallow charges and it goes right
underneath his glove and it trickles
into left field
so haniger is aboard on a play that
archello who's a really fine defensive
third baseman looked like he would make
ten times out of ten the o2
swing line drive corked into left field
for a base hit hanager advances into
second
type france stings the single to left
field and the mariners have two men on
with one out the mariners trying not to
waste what has been
their best offensive inning so far since
the first
that's a rocket
giddy up baby giddy up going we got a
ball game
five four here in the sixth the merc
with a big blast
his seventh of the season
takes his rbi total to 19 a two hit
night for him and just the jolt the
mariners were looking for drew
steckenrider taking over two and two
with a 2.32 era scott's gain a lot of
confidence in this young man here's the
pitch on the way swing animus fire
shella tied him up with a weak wave
at st right three so one out for the
yankees here is the stretch close to
third seeker the 1-1 swinging a fly ball
straight away center field tremel
drifting back well in front of the
warning track this time and he's there
taylor makes the catch for the second
out of the inning tramell has caught
about four fly balls up against the wall
in center field he's been really close
to that padding out there all night long
but this time not as deep as the other
four catches out there so right away two
outs for the yankees and the o2 on the
way swing and a miss for strike three
down goes le castro and what a one two
three top of the eighth inning for drew
steckenrider that's it for new york new
york with a new picture right-hander
jonathan lewis ago will take over in
relief
oh nasty hook
from lewis again seeger down on strikes
well lewisica went right to the power
location down and in with the breaking
ball but it finishes
off the plate at 87 miles an hour and a
great look from the side
as seeger swings right over the top of
it here's the 2-2
he got him
99 down the middle that will retire the
side no runs
one to tie two to win right-hander chad
green takes over in relief here's the
2-2
struck him out swinging ball game over
yankees win
[Applause]
yankees win
now the yankees held on with really
great pitching all night long